Speaker 1: I wanted to cover yesterday's White
House press briefing live, unfortunately,
because of the schedule with the live viewer
town hall yesterday and different things.
I just wasn't able to do it and I regret it
because there were just some amazing moments
at yesterday's White House press briefing
that I want to go through.
Many of these are instructive, and they tell
us a lot about number one, the motivations
of some of the reporters in the White House
press briefing room number two, they really
open us up to very important conversations
about law enforcement in today's case about
paternity leave in today's case and about
many different things.
So let's start with the first one.
The at this point, familiar face in the White
House press briefing room Fox News reporter
Peter Doocy.
He was speechless, speechless as he attempted
another another one of these gotchas of White
House Press Secretary Jen Psaki.
The topic here was about losing police officers
to vaccine mandates when, of course, the reality
is the number one cause of death for law enforcement
over the last year has been COVID not getting
shot in the line of duty.
It's been COVID.
We're going to play the lead up to this and
you will see eventually.
Doocy is just he's he's quite literally speechless.
He doesn't know what to say.
And this is just the continued attempted showboating
that he does.
He maybe thinks this stuff makes him look
good.
It really is.
I mean, he comes off looking like a Smurf
here.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Here we go.
We have a vaccine mandate is to make people
safer.
But a vaccine mandate also means tons of police
and military may walk off the job.
Then at the end of the day, does a vaccine
mandate make people safe?
Speaker 1: Now it's really important every
time they talk about all of these pilots might
quit.
All of these cops might quit.
Remember, we had, for example, we had the
Massachusetts State Police story, oh, of 200
troopers or whatever might threaten the OK?
One of them actually quit.
And so with all of these things, it always
has to be how many people are actually quitting
and getting fired?
We're seeing that it's never more than one
percent in any organization we found
Speaker 3: where tons of police and military
walking off the job,
Speaker 2: right?
The concern is that hundreds of thousands
of U.S. service members remain unvaccinated,
Speaker 1: remain unvaccinated, is different
than they are actually going to be off the
job,
Speaker 2: which is leading to questions about
possible military readiness.
The L.A. County sheriff said been five to
10 percent of their workforce could walk off
the job.
And so considering the fact, I mean, is there
any concern about that?
Speaker 3: Well, I would say what we point
to or what I would point you to is evidence
with a range of companies organizations.
Frankly, the Department of Defense can also
give you the up to date statistics on members
of the military.
I believe it's over 90 percent, but I would
point to them for statistics.
Speaker 2: But there are other problems in
the world than COVID 19.
International terror, gang violence, murder,
arson, drug dealer Was there any concern?
What was the
Speaker 3: Hyatt?
What was the what was the number one cause
of death among police officers last year?
Do you know of COVID 19?
So that's something that we're working to
address.
And police departments are working to address.
If you look at Seattle as an example, which
I know has been in some of the reporting.
Ninety two percent of the police force is
vaccinated.
He's very
Speaker 1: quiet now, isn't he,
Speaker 3: as are?
Ninety three percent of firefighters.
Ninety nine percent of Seattle's 11000 employees
have submitted vaccine verification or an
exemption request
Speaker 2: safety, though all of these other
problems terror murder robberies, kidnapings.
Is there any concern that if police forces
shrink the size of the ready military force
trace that the United States or localities
may not be equipped?
Speaker 1: By the way, the military question
is funny because the military is not supposed
to be used for domestic enforcement of laws.
And there are, of course, as we know, situations
where governors can call out state national
guards.
But like Trump's idea of sending the military
down to the U.S. Mexico border to enforce
the border law, that's actually against the
law.
You're you're not actually.
It's so funny that he talks about we.
What about arson and the military?
What does the military have to do with arson
or robbery?
Speaker 3: Nothing properly to deal with heat,
or more than 700000 people have died of COVID.
Speaker 1: All right.
So you guys get the point.
Now, of course, any any one of you should
be saying, David, is it true?
Is it even true that COVID is the leading
cause of death for law enforcement?
This has been fact checked many, many times.
Here is just one example The officer down
memorial page details the cause of death causes
of death in the line of duty among law enforcement
officers in 2020.
Two hundred and forty five officers died due
to COVID contracting COVID in the line of
duty.
That was the majority of the 374 deaths in
the line of duty.
COVID was by far the most common recorded
cause of death gunfire seconds beginning in
early 2020 due to requirements of their jobs.
Thousands of law enforcement officers and
first responders contracted COVID.
Hundreds of law enforcement officers died
from medical complications as a result of
contracting the virus while remaining on duty
and interacting with the community.
A message at the top of the site reads COVID
is the number one killer of law enforcement
officers in 2020 and 2021.
In 2021, 237 COVID deaths were recorded.
That also makes it a majority 369 total deaths
in the line of Duty 237 for law enforcement
officers.
So it is indeed true.
It is indeed true.
And you can just see, you know, kind of the
confusion on Peter duces face.
There's always some degree of confusion with
all of these things.
And in this case, what we have to remember
is COVID leading cause of death for law enforcement.
No.
Two threats to quit or people who are as of
yet unvaccinated is very different than X
percent of the workforce is now gone.
United Airlines was a big one where they announced
a vaccine requirement for employees.
And then it was, oh my goodness, look at all
these people that are still unvaccinated.
And as the deadline approached and approached
and approached, I think it was like one third
of one percent of United employees actually
remained unvaccinated at the time of the deadline,
one third of one percent, maybe half of one
percent or something like that.
So always keep that in mind, but just speechless.
Speechless.